go the extra mile I think as
entrepreneurs we have opportunities
every single day to go the extra mile in
our business also in our in our family
life and our personal relationships we
always have the opportunity with every
interaction that we have to do a little
bit more to add a little bit more value
to give the person just a little bit
more time energy appreciation doesn't
have to cost you anything maybe it does
but doesn't have to to make the person
feel a little bit more valuable a little
bit more treasured a little bit more
happy we have these opportunities every
single day and most of us don't take
them and that little extra bonus that
you go through could make the difference
between you land in the next big deal
and you just have it in okay business
especially when you do that on a
consistent basis so how I'm applying
this to my book one of the things I'm
certainly getting to markley mode now
one of the things that I'm thinking
about is you know I need other authors
or I'd love to have their support to
help me promote the book get some
exposure from it I have an amazing
audience but I'm one of the people with
their audiences to talk about it too so
one of the things that I'm doing is
turned a little bit earlier and helping
market some of the books ideas thoughts
that other authors already have so I
started one with Ryan Holliday and a
series recently came out we did two
versions of it from his book ego is the
enemy and I made a video of me reading a
section from egos the enemy and
initially I was just to do a typography
video just to like show some of the
words on the screen have some music
track behind it and promote it out there
and I think would be valuable for you
guys the audience and I think Ryan would
would love it he'd love that I put
effort into it to try to help him I
think just making any kind of video
would have been good for him and for
other authors that were going to make
this a series that was the initial
intent and then I thought you know what
I got to go a little bit more we got to
do the extra mile I want to have
something that is so good that Ryan
doesn't just see it and thank me for but
he wants to share it with his audience
to that he wants to tell people about it
because it is so good and so that made
me go
the extra mile I partnered up with two
guys who make motivational videos and I
said guys I want to make an amazing
video I have a script we had a guy who's
part of believe nation bass drop beats
who create an audio track for us and I
want to make a motivational type field
of video and these two guys both put
their spin on it and release it and I'm
proud of both versions of it and Ryan
saw it and shared it would he have
shared it if I didn't do the
motivational video and just did a
typography video maybe what do you still
valued it and appreciated me even if I
didn't go that extra mile probably how
much extra does that me going that extra
mile what does that mean to him in our
relationship I don't know you can't
quantify it but if you get used to going
the extra mile for others and you do it
consistently I guarantee you that a lot
of good things will come back to you and
it's not something that you can quantify
tomorrow but making people feel really
good adding a lot of value to somebody
else's life is guaranteed to come back
to you especially when you're doing it
consistently over time on top of the
fact that it makes you feel good like
going the extra mile to help somebody
out should also make you feel good that
you're adding that extra value and
you're doing good in the world and so it
was an easy decision for the book and i
encourage you to find a way today
tomorrow every day to add just a little
bit extra value go with a little bit
extra mile to help somebody else out in
your business or in your relationships
so let's get to the questions first up
is C do hope i pronounced that okay hey
when you have any tips on how to be more
entertaining when making youtube videos
that's an interesting question if you
are not entertaining I don't know that
you need to be entertaining I'm a big
fan of going all in on your strengths
doing the thing that you're really good
at and not trying to be somebody else so
because Chris Rock is entertaining I
want to be like Chris maybe you're
nothing like Chris and so maybe that
shouldn't be the person that you model
one of the things that I try to do for
Toronto that's also where I'm filming
here for the instructors is let
everybody's personality shine so we have
multiple instructors I have Alex and
Lisa and Lou
in Jessica and Philippe and Katarina and
we've got tons of instructors and they
all teach a lot of tips of same material
but they teach it in their own style you
know Alex who you've seen on the channel
a couple times is really funny and makes
a lot of bloopers and it makes everybody
laugh and is silly if you don't have
that personality you know like me I'm
not the silliest guy I don't make a lot
of mistakes I don't have a lot of
bloopers for me to try to be like Alex
it wouldn't it wouldn't work out right
like I can't be Alex and nor should i be
and Alex shouldn't want to try to be me
either like there may be some things he
can model but he needs to go all in on
that because that's where he's really
going to shine and so every instructor
needs to have what they're really good
at and go all in on that and so if
you're even asking the question how to
be more entertaining it kind of speaks
to the fact that you're probably not
entertaining and so maybe you shouldn't
even worry about it at all do you and
know that you can provide a ton of value
by being yourself and being comfortable
with yourself next up dr phoenix
congrats on the book look forward to
reading your book and your awesome
acknowledgments LOL thank you for that i
really appreciate the support and love
and that honestly helped me through a
lot of this process of writing the book
and making this series has been super
helpful so thank you and looking forward
to support once the book comes out Macy
I don't read paper books i only listen
to audiobooks we've talked about a
couple times good news is there is an
audiobook version coming I don't know
when it's gonna be recorded but it's
coming so for those of you who do love
audio books they'll be a version for you
again I'm still overwhelmed by how many
people want an audio version versus a
paperback but I'm glad we're having both
for you Michael Archuleta great stuff
your video editor is badass I agree
Christina you are badass choreographic
arts me me me I want the audiobook the
audiobook is going to be better than to
understand then read my dyslexia is the
reason why I'm learning from videos and
audio books instead to read them so yeah
audio book it is that's interesting I am
much more visual learner and so probably
not doing some YouTube videos talking
about some of the concept as well so you
can learn from it for me would go a
video then
eating then audio I feel like I had the
hardest time learning just listening for
example if Nina is asking me something
or she's watching the video and she
tells me about it I'd have to go watch
the video to really understand it or
much rather see it written out then have
her tell me something sometimes just the
way that I process we video then written
and then audio I'm curious how where do
you guys fall between video written word
and audio what's your order of
preference from learning styles leave it
down in the comments I'm curious to see
what that order is for me for you
because what is for me Alec way to keep
it real I love how everything is about
value this isn't worth much but chat up
to you you upload multiple videos a day
all have the same purpose look at this
series 54 episodes and it's still going
love it don't end the series a lot in
there thank you out like I think one it
is valuable like the shout out is
valuable for me I appreciate it it's
part of the reason why I do these this
series for you is because you're finding
value in it so I want to be able to
share that so don't underestimate the
value of a shout out to somebody you've
new heights of success just somebody
saying that you've impacted them mean
something and so if anything I'd
encourage you to try to do it more for
other people that you look up to and
benefit from and learn from maybe that's
a good assignment like today go thank
somebody another YouTube or someone else
in your in your life or in your business
that has had an impact and just write
them a note to say thank you because
it's a cold breed of person that doesn't
feel what you know warm-hearted from
getting that kind of message to them in
terms of the making the videos on the
same content yeah i mean i'm all about
believe i think when you find your one
word when you know what you staying for
then it becomes way easier to build a
business to live a life everything that
I do is around believe somehow and just
become much easier I'm not trying to
make content just to rank for some
search sermon just to drive tons of
traffic to my my channel I make it
because I care deeply about the topics
that I'm covering as for ending the
series I don't plan to I'm thinking I'm
probably gonna go into marketing mode
talking to you already today's video is
more about
marketing about the creative process but
we'll see you know as long as you guys
enjoy I'll keep doing it new future
builder I look forward to the series on
tds when it starts because I'm sure it
will it's coming I'm sure it's coming i
gotta figure out the execution but a
series on tds whether it's on my channel
or on tds as youtube channel right now
all the content on our youtube channel
tds is just turn patterns moves that you
can do in salsa and doesn't really speak
to the culture what we're trying to
build so that's going to be changing
soon and the reality show yeah one of
our channels probably tds not her
percent sure though but i like the
feedback we'll see where it goes run the
young question i was wondering where you
had your Evan Carmichael believe wall
decal sticker made oh that's a good
question I believe it I found it online
it was the biggest size that they had I
wish I was in I was at the office so I
could have it up behind me I think it's
Fathead com it's a strange name came
super affordable apparently it's a it's
a peel away that you can take it off and
put it back on if you need to so I'd
recommend checking them out next up is
gel however i have a question I have an
amazing idea it's an app for
entrepreneurs I know it tells a problem
because it causes me a problem I don't
know anything about designing apps now i
could pay others for doing this but it's
just a way to go my question is how
would you solve this my answer for you
gel would be I would find a partner you
could hire somebody to make this thing
for you the challenge though is it's
really hard to have a successful tech
company without somebody who understands
tech right like you want somebody who
lives and brews and feels this with you
just like you do not someone just
creates code to match a work order you
want someone who actually loves this and
has new ideas and new energy to bring to
you so I try to partner up with an app
developer who feels the same struggle
that you're feeling and that this app
will solve and if they bring the
technical side and you bring the
business or marketing side I think
that's the best way that's how we try to
solve it if I didn't have the skills
syed is writing in relation to being
bored how do you spend your weekends
Evan that's an interesting question one
we often have something related to salsa
dancing so I'm new owner of trying to
dance salsa I met Nina through salsa
dancing and so we often have some kind
of event whether it's a friday night
party or saturday night party so we're
often at one of our events that we do
it's still something that I enjoy I
enjoy dancing thankfully when I took
over the business I removed myself from
some of the tasks because it was I was
fined was just too much and was taken
away my love of the business and that
the art of dancing and so by removing
myself from some of those things I like
dancing a lot more again and so I'm off
dancing usually at least two to three
times a week on top of teaching one of
the classes sunday i teach level six
which is our most advanced class so I'm
here every Sunday doing that I'll
usually do something with Hayden it's
warm outside now so we're off maybe
playing catch in the park or spending
time with his cousins whatever it is
just something outside and then saturday
i usually plan a day for Nina she takes
care of most of my most of our weekday
stuff in planes and we were pretty
hectic schedule so saturday is on me and
they're usually planning a full day
surprise Nina loves food and so I take
her to different places that have popped
up in Toronto with different new foods
for her to try and that's it usually
saturdays a full day we start off the
day at Tim Hortons getting our coffee
and breakfast and then now that summer
will hop on the best spot and bounced
around from different places whether the
festival or different restaurants or you
know find outdoor activities just
something new that she hasn't tried
before to add a little bit more fun and
less boringness to our lives on a
regular basis so that's how I serve our
weekends how do you guys spend your
weekends leave in the comments so thank
you guys so much for watching really
enjoyed all the questions I'd love to
know what you think about the topic
which was going the extra mile how do
you do it you have questions about it if
you also have any questions about the
book writing process or my book leave in
the comments below and I will answer you
in next week's video thank you guys so
much for watching that means a lot to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon